I'm sweaty there's a bride product of
being fat so if you see a little couple
sweat droplets on me [ __ ] you let it go
let it go let it grow let it grow when
you see a big booty you laugh it's a
reference to my penis
I was going on YouTube now one of you
[ __ ] sent me this article this
artful about KFC I know it's not about
McDonald's and I have a lot of faith
towards them you [ __ ] won't sponsor
me so [ __ ] it
now if you guys haven't read about the
story there was this kid in Stockton
that said he found a brain in his box of
KF sizzle and what kind of brain you ask
a chicken brain now going to the article
he's pretty upset that he actually got a
chicken part and his box a chicken man
you want to have my opinion about this
[ __ ] the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever
heard in my life how are you gonna
complain that you got a piece of a
chicken in your box Oh chicken that's
right it could possibly be a chicken
brain you know how I know you're not
Asian you [ __ ] made a complaint about
it Asian people wouldn't complaint it
they got chicken brain in it that shit's
a delicacy oh yeah what the hell must be
my lucky babe I feel like people in
America are so desensitized when it
comes to their food and you
[ __ ] don't know where your
chicken comes from yes your chicken was
once a whole living being somebody was
in a factory they took a knife so let me
explain it to you American people why
people Mexican people chicken got legs
got wings got feathers it was cutting
around one day and then one Chinese lady
said oh yeah what I chopped off his
[ __ ] head man you got Cassie [ __ ]
now if you're said about your food
because you got a chicken brain in it I
understand you know what it's your food
you should have gone to the [ __ ]
manager and said hey you know what I got
a [ __ ] brain in my box can I get a
new box chicken you don't think you
would've got a new box of fried chicken
and your money back you probably would
and then all honestly I guarantee you
that what's even the [ __ ] chicken
brain that was the part you know the
part when you get like a chicken breast
as I don't know love bones a kidney or
some [ __ ] I don't know but I love that
part although what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you we all know that Mexican and
Asian people we should always know where
our food comes from we [ __ ] slaughter
[ __ ] like it's nothing true story I
actually used to have chickens in my
backyard I actually had two of them and
I named them a roux fish and do fish did
we had this dude from Korea stay with us
we called him Tae Yong ki hyung
this [ __ ] one day said you know
what I'm gonna cook dinner for y'all so
a few hours later it was dinnertime and
he came out with his delicious chicken
dish and I hate the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
it and of course the child the next
morning I went to go look at my chickens
to play with him um I think I was more
surprised the fact that I actually
they were my pets and even give a [ __ ] I
knew something was wrong when it was 6
a.m.
cockadoodledoo but I got a defend camp
see on this one they do nothing wrong if
you put a chicken break the box that's
just a bonus it's just like proof that
it was an actual real chicken BAM
that's why I didn't really understand
like that whole thing with McDonald's
you guys remember when that dude got
that chicken nugget box and there was a
[ __ ] chicken hitting it and he was
like oh man you guys are the one that
said MacDonnell's don't even serve real
chicken [ __ ] well you know you got a
whole chicken hand how real is that ha
ha talking about it's not real food then
why the [ __ ] you eating it dumbass if
you guys want to know out there how I
got this wonderful marvelous body
mekka do not go but I don't blame
McDonald's or KFC for making me fat
that's all on me people out there that
blame fast-food for them being out of
shape is just [ __ ] stupid you went
like Colonel Sanders came to your
[ __ ] door said hey ching chong eat my
[ __ ] chicken I'm not sure but Colonel
Sanders looked like a slave owner so I'm
assuming he's racist why Colonel Sanders
is like he owned 14 slaves and live on a
plantation if Colonel Sanders was still
alive he probably spent me to build him
a train track [ __ ] and dude that put it
on Instagram I'm pretty sure you use did
that for fun I'm not giving you [ __ ] I'm
is more or less surprised that people
are disgusted when they see a certain
animal part that's next to the stuff
that they're eating animals are killed
in order for you to eat them ok I'm ok
with that fact I'm not a vegan and I
don't want to hear [ __ ] from a [ __ ]
vegan calling me a [ __ ] murderer
[ __ ] you let me tell you something else
if meat was not made to consume
why the [ __ ] it tastes so good [ __ ] and
you know there's one thing I wish like
McDonald's would change is probably
Ronald McDonald that will look scary as
[ __ ] I'm sorry I'm sorry I support you
like a hundred percent but Ronald
McDonald is like a clown if he turned
into a rapist
you tell me right now that every time
you go by KFC you don't think that he
looks like a [ __ ] racist repot
[ __ ] check out eat my [ __ ] chicken
[ __ ] eat my [ __ ] chicken fly toss